[Music]
on today's show we talked to an
awesome woman who is tired of burning up
her relationships with her sharp tongue
with her judging her poking
we also talked to a great young man
who's feeling guilty about making way
more money than his parents
we've got good news on the psychological
resilience front
[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john deloney show
the originally titled show
i don't know i'm yelling i don't even
know why i'm yelling i think
every time i say the name of the show i
think that's what we came up with
man we worked really hard for hours and
hours to come up with a show
that we could have just called my mom
and asked her what we should name it
nothing cool like i don't know after
lasers or spaceships or dinosaurs or
dragons but
we do have the dr john delonay's show
hey this is a show about mental health
about
your life about your family's parenting
um education anything that is going on
in your life that we can
walk alongside you man that's why we're
here that's why we're here love to have
you on the show we get callers from all
over planet earth
um if you want to be on the show give me
a call at 1-844-693-3291
it's 1-844-693-329
leave a message tell me what's going on
in your life and how we might be able to
help
and uh we kelly will give you a call and
we will
have you on the show or if you are more
of the
internet's type go to johndaloney.com
ask ask
and we would love to get you on so a
couple of cool things
james is out of town this week he is um
working at a middle school camp
i love everybody on earth but i think
i'd rather set myself on fire than work
for a week at a middle school camp
sleeping in cabins with middle schoolers
so james
is a better person at the end of the day
than most of us
but we got ben hill sitting in on the
knobs
and that is awesome and kelly
lovely kelly's here we're so excited to
have everybody here
um hey listen i want to tell you guys
this this is a big deal
so my son was in texas and he was with
my in-laws
and they were scrolling through i don't
know they were gonna watch andy griffith
show some
18th century black and white show and
they were scrolling through
on the somehow youtube was on the scroll
and it had my show on it and so
in my son's mind the john de loni show
on youtube
is is like on amazon like which puts it
at par with
other movies like disney channel movies
so it's like frozen
one into jurassic park the john delaney
show makes sense right
in my head it's exactly how that plays
out
so he got all excited and he called me
and he said dad dad you're not going to
believe this well when he does that
usually that means he's
caught some snake or a turtle or went
fishing or something like that
so he calls and says dad you're not
going to believe this my daughter's
cheering in the background
dad you're on tv and i said i know
that's what pays our rent
right and he said no no like you were on
amazon we were scrolling and you were on
the
scroll thing i said that's great
i'm i'm glad that you guys get to know
what i do for a living
and then he said and dad
you're fat and i said
what and he's like man
i saw you on the tv dad and you're fat
i said i don't think i am i i don't
think so
i work out a lot i think i'm i i don't
think so son
and he said no dad i saw your face it
makes it huge and mushy
that was his exact words my face is huge
and mushy
to which i said hey man is your mom
there i'm sad
and josephine my daughter got on she
goes daddy you're fat
so listen um i haven't eaten in 72 hours
and i'm just
jogging straight through this one just
kidding i'm not
but it is true these cameras make you
look huge
and so i don't know i don't think i
ben you're you're new does my face look
mushy not at all i disagree
my son would tell me the truth you
wouldn't you have a vested interest in
lying and keeping
propping up my self-esteem which i'm
grateful for
oh man gotta love my children
dude i wanna support you and your face
looks mushy
so throughout the show i'll be sucking
my cheeks in everybody
old ben affleck style and i think we're
good all right let's go to the phones
let's go to lorraine
in miami florida love rain
it kind of sounds like roxanne but i'm
gonna go with lorraine how in the world
are you
i've been better but i'm awesome as well
how are you doing
that's i've been the exact same you've
said that perfectly
this is kind of uh not my best but it's
still pretty good right
listen we're standing so we just got to
go forward that's it
that's all we can do i don't even know
what that means but i'm going to go with
it it sounds incredible
i'm a huge i'm a huge collector of
sayings
that if you just write them down and
read them they don't make a lot of sense
but they feel good when they come out
so you know what lorraine today i'm
standing and that means i'm just going
to go forward
awesome so we can do hey so what's
what's going on how can i help
thank you for telling about your own
personal life it really really i don't
know if you know this really helps the
listeners you know
really really helps so i just wanted to
thank you for that well thank you so
much
it feels like a train wreck most days
but i appreciate you yeah i hear you
appreciate you so hey dr john uh my
question is this
i have a personality malfunction
oh awesome okay a personality function
tell me about it yeah
it's kind of deep for me so um
i notice a pattern with myself that
my personality can get really blunt
okay and really straightforward and
really like
the cards are on the table now and i
don't like
bs i don't like when i s when somebody's
saying something but their energy is
different
i don't like passive aggressive like for
me like i'm just such a straight shooter
which is awesome if you like me
but if you don't like yeah like if my
friends that love me like they like that
part of me right
but but then i get into situations with
people that i like actually love
like my little sister two friends and
now my boyfriend
we're like if i feel slighted
or something is unjust in some way like
the gloves are off yeah the gloves are
off the glass is awesome so
so let me just let me just give you some
context
boyfriend and i had a situation where he
kind of insinuated
because i had given a half hug to
somebody
after he had heard me over speaker phone
talking to my girlfriend
that i wasn't a big hugger and so
because she was going through something
i said hey i'm going to give you a hug
through the phone she said hey i
appreciate that and you're not a big
hugger
so he overheard this wasn't a big deal
later on in the day we had ran into an
acquaintance of mine who was a guy
we you know i introduced uh i give
and this this started a kind of snowball
with him
and i thought
this really sucks because like i didn't
do anything right
and so now i feel insinuated but that
plays into
a year and a half ago i was falsely
accused of something at work
and it really took me out at the knees
and i lost my salary i lost my office i
lost
a lot of things and he knows that and so
when that happened
i just was like came like right into
this space of like whoa
this is happening again yep so i calmed
down the situation actually and i was
very proud of myself
i didn't react i calmed down you know we
went for a drive i gave him
his space we ended up talking after and
i said hey is this something i got to
worry about in the future
like if every time i go to touch
somebody whatever it's going to be a big
deal like i
i can't handle that right i can't i'm
telling you that right now
so that's my boundary so then five days
yeah thank you so then five days later
he's on a business trip
and he insinuated again
i'm sorry but like i just now i just
felt so like
like slighted like i put a lot of energy
and time and love into the relationship
and now all i can do is go back to that
time at my work
where where it's like i didn't i didn't
do that
hey lorraine do that yeah tell me
when you were a kid somebody hurt you
real real bad
who was it
see the only one there may be more than
one
more yeah high school age
like between 16 20.
uh i think it started uh very young but
that
that definitely hyped it that was the
age of heights
did people take things from you between
16 20 16 21 22.
i think my whole life has just been kind
of a little bit tragic i've had a little
bit of a
heartbreak that i've kind of carried
with me okay and so i
i see that and i see that that's how i'm
like reacting out of that
yeah i guess my thing is yeah and i get
that and i notice that just in the
moment this alarm bell goes off and it's
like holy [ __ ] it's like that sorry
my language the train leaves the station
yeah and i there you go i like i
ca so my question is how do i get the
train not to leave the station because
these are people i actually genuinely
care about
yeah so here's the deal you um
i've known and loved people just like
your situation
okay like like
for a long long time and
your body your heart your mind is on
high high high alert all the time
and my guess is it you don't sleep very
deeply
my guess is you don't relax very much
um my guess is that
you love really really intensely but
that you're
always on alert for a slight something's
coming your way something's coming after
you
and you will beat everybody to the punch
yeah and you will go to war on your own
behalf
even as you can watch your body gearing
up and taken off on you
and you start your the thinking part of
your brain tries to stop it
and it's already off to wars firing
shots before your head even gets there
right and so here's the thing
that is a gift that's how all of us are
made
our brains will identify and go to war
or take off running from a threat before
we can even consciously see it or feel
it
okay it mobilizes and goes
and that's how i'm almost positive
you had some sort of what i would call
traumatic childhood or somebody or some
group of people hurt you or some sort of
abuse or some sort of neglect
some sort of like you mom who tried to
live through you
or perfection some sort of something has
put
your high alert so
finely tuned so finely tuned
and here's what happens is
you've got this finely tuned army ready
to go to war at the drop of a hat
and you have a body that has to have
human connection yeah you have to have
people who will hold your hand
and touch your arm and not use you for
sex but will be intimate with you
and who will laugh with you and so
you've got these two competing factions
one
desperate desperate for human touch and
connection
and the other desperate to never let you
get hurt again
and so that's why folks in your
situation often have
love them some opiates love them
some alcohol or weed love them
meth right because that ends up being a
cheap way to get that connection
without having to let the army
take a break because if the army takes a
break then we make it hurt again
okay and you didn't mention anything
about addiction that's a whole other
conversation
um but there's just an exhaustion factor
so here's the thing
that you're gonna have to allow yourself
to enter into
okay you've got to stop
being the judge and jury of every person
around you
i know it's so tiring it's exhausting
but listen it's so exhausting you can't
stop doing that
until you decide i'm gonna be vulnerable
with other people
and what vulnerability means it's an
it's a term
from the animal kingdom often that i'm
rolling over on my back
and i'm gonna allow my soft underbelly a
chance to be hurt
and that means you're gonna have to
stare down face to face
heart to heart whatever your body's
trying to protect you from
and it may be years of stuff
but you're gonna have to let your heart
and mind know that was then
and i'm safe now and
i'm gonna have to teach my body over and
over and over again
i'm okay i'm safe and what happens when
you're vulnerable
lorraine as you get hurt again but it
won't be as bad as the
as the the times that your body circle
up the wagons on you
right and ultimately
you're able to just drop your shoulders
and you're able to just be with people
and roll your eyes instead of having to
come back at somebody
or when your boyfriend says oh i thought
you were in a hugger
i saw you hug that guy you can just take
whatever towel you have in your hand and
whap him with it and go you're an idiot
and then go about your day
because it's not existential right what
i could do that's what i wanted to do
like if i look back in the conversation
you know
yeah just be cool natalie just be chill
just say
i'm gonna kiss your whole damn face if
you say that again or whatever
exactly but here's what you're trying to
do yes yeah i do i do i
totally a hundred percent 100 know what
you mean
but until you decide to let the army
have a break your brain and your body
are going to continue to go to war on
your behalf
and here's the thing how old are you 41.
41 this has been happening for a long
long time so here's the thing you're not
broken
there's not something dysfunctional with
you but you
i think of it as a learning disorder
okay you have learned a way to protect
yourself
and it has protected you and now it's
costing you everything
right yeah yeah and so what you have to
do
is learn new ways to be safe and to feel
safe
and you're going to do that with other
people not through building higher walls
around yourself
so how do you have a suggestion on how
to even start that
i mean i felt like i was very vulnerable
with this person i said i really loved
myself
when i in this relationship like i was
like wow yeah sally like
you're doing it you know what i mean
there's okay there's two two things you
can do
number one to heal over time like you're
talking about you're gonna have to go
meet with somebody
okay and they're gonna walk alongside
you here's the second thing
you're gonna have to practice when you
screw up
when your body goes to war against
somebody who was like what
what are you doing you're gonna have to
be able to look at him and say that was
ridiculous and i'm sorry
that's 30 year old lorraine trying to
protect me and i'm sorry i know you're
just being goofy
and so i'm gonna do a redo ready say it
again
and they're going to say and then you're
going to practice again and here's what
you're going to do
in short short order lorraine because
you you are a loving person a caring
person
and i bet that when you're fully firing
you are a blast to be around is that
right i
am i am see i guarantee you and then you
get
one too many drinks and somebody looks
at you wrong and it is world war three
am i right
no no not with that no no
i'm actually really cool so it's the
other way
so everyone loves three drink lorraine
that's when sweetheart comes out
like we're cool like yeah we're cool oh
no
all right hey that's a recipe for
disaster i know
and it's my it's my recipe that i've
kind of stirred up here and therefore
i'm calling because i'm like
i love it i love it okay yeah now that
like i've heard enough people
and i hurt myself okay yeah now where'd
i go from here so here's what you're
gonna do
you're gonna get connected in
your hometown and you're gonna reach out
to a counselor
and you're gonna let them know hey for
35 years
i've been going to war and i'm tired i
want to learn to be graceful with myself
i want to learn to be graceful with
those around me i want to stop being the
judge and jury
and hey part of it is just stop being
the judge and jury when you feel your
body
looking at somebody going oh my gosh
whatever what
just literally say to yourself stop not
your job
your job is to have fun here and enjoy
your friends when a friend says
something or a family member who you
know
loves you and your first thought is to
snap at them to be judgment
to swing at them catch yourself and when
you don't catch yourself
say i'm sorry i didn't mean to do that
and that is
learning how to be vulnerable learning
how to connect with
other people decide i am
not going to have that third drink
i'm not going to have a chemical crutch
to allow me to be kind i'm going to
learn to be kind and
fun and gentle on my own and here's what
i'm telling you
almost guarantee lorraine this is going
to dig
up old stuff he's going to dig up a lot
of old stuff and you're going to have to
have a professional to walk alongside
you
what i will tell you is you can learn
different ways to interact
think about this think about if people
left their experience with you a little
more peaceful than when they joined you
if they left their time with you a
little more
calm and a little more loving of
themselves than when they
entered your presence
that is a that's something i long for
and i work towards
because lorraine i'm like you man i'm
judging everybody i
my natural default is to just be
all lit up all the time and i've worked
for a decade now
to make it the opposite i want people to
be more calm when they come in my
presence and so i'm telling you from
firsthand experience
you can get there call somebody today
sit down with your boyfriend and say hey
listen the other day i just went off the
rails and i'm sorry
here's a couple of things change your
identity
you're gonna be a person who people
gravitate towards who they love being
around not who they
are have one eye open towards because
they're nervous they're scared
right number two invite people into
accountability
invite your boyfriend or a couple of
close girlfriends or
your niece to be able to say hey that
was too much
that hurt and then be able to say
okay i'm gonna take a walk around the
house i'm gonna say i'm sorry i'm gonna
exhale
because i know that that was on me
okay um number three when you're about
to
light off when you're about to set
somebody on fire when you're about to
lash out at somebody
the magic moment here is catching
yourself and saying
stop stop stop stop
what am i trying to protect myself from
is this person really going to try to
hurt me
no is my boyfriend just clowning around
about a hug
yes if a person at work keeps
miss miss um keeps
thinking that my hugs or my
affection or my connection with them is
inappropriate then lorraine you gotta
stop
you gotta stop quit hugging people right
put touch up whatever the thing is
right just work hard to stop
go see somebody make this about your
identity
seek accountability and then for crying
out loud
learn to stop yourself before you lash
just learn
before you make that comment before you
jump all over somebody before you judge
somebody else's
clothes or the way they rolled their
eyes or the joke they just told
just stop just stop and man that heart
that you've been hiding for so long is
gonna be such a gift to so many people
lorraine it's awesome
all right thanks for the call you are
the best all right let's go to chris
in denver what's up chris hey dr dee
thanks for taking my call how you doing
today you got it brother what's going on
man
um i'd love to chat with you about um
how to work through
feeling guilty and maybe even some
imposter syndrome
as it relates to my career as i compare
it to my parents
and the income they made earlier when i
was growing up huh
tell me about it great question i get
this question a lot man so
i'm glad you're we're connecting here
yeah i appreciate it you've been a great
addition to ramsey and i feel like the
the mindset part of finance is super
important so
i'm happy to happy to have you help me
help or you help me
whatever we're trying to do here there
you go um so so growing up i
grew up pretty blue-collar my dad worked
three jobs he would be a mailman all day
after that he'd be a landscaper after
that he'd be a bartender he'd get home
at 2 am
and then right back at it the next day
and he busted his butt to to be where he
was and to raise us
and and now i have a really good job i
make a lot of money and
i i don't work nearly as hard as he does
and
i kind of struggle with that and they
still struggle they still
you know barely make ends meet and i'm
you know living a good life and
they wouldn't accept my help even if i
wanted to so i don't know it's just uh
it's a lot
what do you feel guilty i'm more
emotional yeah more emotional talking
about it than
uh than i thought it would be no it's
hard man i appreciate you
being honest and vulnerable i know
millions of people
i don't know them but there are millions
of people in your exact same situation
that have found themselves in a
different life setting than they grew up
in
and they don't know what to do with it
and they thought this new setting would
solve their problems would
make them feel a certain way and it
doesn't and that feels there's a
disconnect there right
so um
man there's a lot here what makes you
uncomfortable about
being successful
um i just was never raised with money
like i never asked my parents for
you are giving money a lot of power
where does that power come from
probably insecurity about not having a
lot growing up okay
and so money was supposed to solve
everything why hasn't it solved
everything
um i don't know it's a great question
i mean i'm happy in in my life it's it's
just when i look back towards my parents
that
they don't have that and i feel bad so
can i ask you a like a
i'm going to phrase this in a way that's
going to set you up is that cool okay
cool
um who gave you permission to judge your
parents
no one who gave you the right
to look at your parents and say wow
they're missing out they should have x y
or z they could be happier if they only
had x y or z
because you have x y or z and you're not
happier
yeah is there a chance that they're
doing okay
yeah they're i mean they're doing fine
yeah
and so what is it about you having money
that makes you feel like
they could or should or might have
um i've just seen them make some
interesting financial decisions that
i think if they had money they wouldn't
have done that's fair and by interesting
you mean terrible
ridiculous stupid uh your words not mine
yeah they're not my parents man i don't
have to defend them good for you though
um so here's here's
my dad's a cop growing up and then he
quit being a cop
halfway through my life and became a
minister at a local church
okay we didn't have a lot growing up
and what i found and this is not
something that my dad did
this is something that somehow i
internalized
i divided the world up into us's and
thems
and when you live a life of stress
whenever your body sounds the alarms and
you go into fight or flight it quickly
has
a mechanism by which it divides up who's
on my team and who's not
and we're gonna run or go to war with
those who are not on our team and we're
gonna double down on those who are on
our team
if you look at our country over the last
30 or 40 years
one of the things that media has done so
well
particularly advertising is when they
tap into the fight-or-flight part of
your brain
you feel like you need to go do a thing
to get a thing or to go to a thing
what does that mean in brass tax it
means you go buy stuff to make yourself
feel better
okay or you go to war and how do you go
to war you go buy some more stuff we
need some more gear some more this some
more of that
or you escape you go on vacations right
and so
companies have a vested interest in you
staying
buzzed up and then you look at the
political landscape
50 years later and i don't care who you
vote for chris
but there's some things that the people
you vote for you're like ah that's
probably a bit much
right but yeah since you're in an us
in them you start biting off things that
the us's are doing
you don't even agree with because it's
not them right so i'm i'm telling you
that to tell you
if you grew up in a blue-collar world
there is some part of your life that is
absorbed into this is who we are and
this is who
they are whoever they is and all of a
sudden you look up with a great job and
a great salary in a big house and you
realize oh no i'm a vey
yeah and then what you have to do is
either
convince yourself that the us's that you
grew up with were wrong
and we got to burn it to the ground and
i got to fix them and help
them or help the us's become one of
these
right yeah or
you live this gapped life where
so my last job in texas um
i was i put in for a promotion i didn't
get it and i didn't know why i
was even i wasn't even um considered
right they didn't give me an interview
for it and so i asked a buddy who was
ahead of me
on this on the hierarchy and he said man
people
think you're a politician i was like
what are you talking about
i said man you always hang out with the
cops in the back of the room you always
hang out with the caterers
and you're in there in a suit it looks
like you're just glad handing and i said
man that's where i feel most comfortable
because i don't feel comfortable hanging
out with the academics i don't feel
comfortable hanging out with the
administrators he looked at me and said
you're an academic administrator my
brother you have ph
two phds you're looking you are now
being the jerk you've been trying to
avoid and that hit me because he was
right
you know what i mean i was pretending
and so here's what i would tell you
be really grateful for what you got
and i am don't feel like you've got to
live in both worlds
okay be a person who treats everyone you
come into contact with
with gratitude with kindness
make sure you acknowledge the mailman
right because you know how that life is
damn
love love love your old man he's a grown
man he can make the choices that he
wants to make
and they're not for you to judge right
but he's a guy for you to love
and have you learned tell me
if
you are i'm trying to say this in a
graceful kind way
i uh man
you can just say it well
i can but man i don't want to get
canceled so here's the deal
if we look over the last 100 years
in our country in the western world the
stock market has done what
gone way up way up it's gone way up we
all got rich
and i know those people listening to
this like i'm not rich you are you are
and also what has gone up is
diseases of despair addiction
cancers strokes heart attacks
um people in jail
so it's come at a cost is what i'm
saying
all sorts of social ills have come at
the cost of us getting wealthy
and i'm not saying that getting wealthy
is bad or evil or wrong
it's not the pursuit
single-mindedly of it is killing us
and so what i would challenge you do you
live by your old man
no i don't how close are you
2 000 miles oh dang gina okay that's a
long way so how often do you all talk
uh once a week i just come home like a
handful of times a year
cool so here's what i want you to do
something
one of two things are going to be weird
and cheesy all right
and just shake it off and get over it
cool
yep yes okay great
hey listen when we hang up i know you're
not going to do either of these but i
just want to tell you it will be awesome
if you do
okay so all right here we go i want you
to
ask your old man dad i want to
start reading a book with you you're
smarter than me and wiser than me you
have been to people's houses for
30 or 40 years you've met with people
bartending
like and you have done landscape you've
done it all i don't know what makes your
head tick and i want to learn about
things that you like so i want to start
reading a book with you
old man you read the book i'll read it
and then we'll talk about it
and if he won't do that some dads don't
read that's fine
y'all can watch a show i want you to
start having a shared experience
together where you're going to talk to
one another
and in that discussion you can either
email
if you're really gangster you can write
letters but i want you to
create some sort of exchange dialogue
with your dad we all write back and
forth
back and forth to each other often men
are terrible
myself included at sitting down with
other men and just talking about hey
what's going on in your life how's it
going
man those are skills that i'm
consistently trying to learn
um but writing man i've seen writing get
to the souls of men in ways that just
chitchatting won't so commit to writing
back and forth whether it's about a book
whether it's about a show whether it's
about fill in the blank
back and forth and back and forth and
back and forth and here's what i'm
trying to get at
i want you to take money out of the
relationship with your dad
your dad's made choices that your dad
made man
he made choices that he made your
choices to
have a um a better life are number one
built on his hard work ethic number two
built off the the lessons of character
and
um relationship building that only a
bartender and a mailman can pass along
to a son
and number three doesn't matter man
doesn't matter it hasn't made your life
it's it's maybe made your life more
comfortable but it hasn't fixed that
hole in your heart that hole in your
heart can only be fixed through
relationships man
so reach it reach out start
relationships with your dad
and it may not look like that it may be
weird you all may intentionally get
together once every five months now
or i mean once every two months now or
three months now it's hard when you're
2000 miles away i get that
could be a facetime conversation once a
week i mean you're talking about awkward
those would be weird man be awkward
and you my brother you start a gratitude
journal today
every day write down the things you are
grateful for
don't sentence yourself to a life of
misery because you're financially
successful
give like crazy give
give give be grateful and when you feel
yourself starting to beat yourself
up because oh yeah i'm a they now and
i'm not one of the uses
it's fine the us's and thems is a fake
category anyway
propagated by every by the air we
breathe nowadays
okay be graceful with yourself be
grateful for your old man dude
[Music]
connection connection relationships all
right brother thanks for the call chris
hey um we'll be right back i'll take a
quick break we'll be right back
[Music]
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even text
chat counseling
with licensed therapists that are going
to help you
become a better version of yourself help
you
get on the road to being well go to
betterhelp.com10
off your first month this is less
expensive than traditional therapy
and you're worth it betterhelp.com
deloney take care of yourself start
today
hey good folks we are back hey listen
hey
i always say hey listen and you're
already listening it's so annoying
oh my gosh i'm gonna try this again
hey everybody we're back so glad to have
you
listen i'm gonna i just did it again
why so annoying i'm gonna keep
practicing at this whole
radio podcast thing in one day good
folks one day
so i ran across a
article this week um i think that my
good friend preston sent it to me
and it is remarkable not surprising at
all and i wanted to pass it along to you
we'll link to it in the show notes
it's an article from the atlantic
written by laura acknan
jamil zaki and elizabeth dunn i'm
confident that i just misspelled those
names
they are researchers at various
universities um
stanford simon frazier um others listen
all right here's the deal i'm gonna
start giving kelly
five dollars every time i say the word
listening because i just said it again
five bucks
i'm all for that perspective immediately
just come in over the thing
and let us all know perfect all right
not you
then just kidding i'll pay you give me
five dollars too
everybody in the booth five dollars for
you five dollars for you everybody
thanks oprah here's the
all right the name of the article is the
pandemic did not affect
mental health and the way you think so
like me i did it every mental health
professional i knew when the pandemic
set off
we all just looked at the
alleged death toll the fear-mongering
the true and real
fear the lockdown the isolation
the economic disaster the coming
economic disaster
the phrase the looming or the coming
fill in the blank
right whatever it was
and early on we saw devastating
anxiety numbers depression numbers
financial numbers
it was distress was just
climbing through the roof these
researchers say it climbed
dramatically right all over the world
and i'm going to read here but as spring
turned to summer something remarkable
happened
average levels of depression this is in
2020
and distress began to fall some data
sets even suggested that overall
psychological distress
returned to pre-pandemic levels by early
summer 2020.
looking at the world as a whole we saw
no trace of a decline in life
satisfaction
people in 2020 rated their lives at a
5.75 on average
identical to the average in previous
years so what does this mean
it's a story as old as time
and it's it's based in neuroscience
which is our brains have a vested
interest
in looking for the worst case scenario
and then trying to reverse engineer that
so that we don't die
our brains have a vested interest in
saying yeah but this might happen
and so we need to be careful about the
might the could be the maybes
and that is why we can't stop scrolling
that's why we can't stop watching news
headlines
that have disaster or looming or crisis
in the titles
that's why we can't stop watching the
stock market tick up and down and down
and up and up and down and down and up
and up and down
the the last time i saw the market a few
weeks ago
it was uh it's up some insane number
but it talked about oh it's down a
hundred points because of
it was a hundred points down that day
after being ten
thousand points up over the last few
years i mean it's just madness right
but our brains are so hardwired to look
for the next
hole in the ground the next thing that
might jump out behind a tree and eat us
but the tale as old as time is we are
incredibly
resilient we can overcome
adapt to solve for so many things
and as the authors write the pandemic
has been a test of the global
psychological immune system
which appears more robust than we ever
could have guessed
when familiar sources of enjoyment
evaporated in the spring of 2020 people
got creative
they participated in drive-by birthday
parties mutually assisted groups virtual
cocktail evenings with old friends
and nightly cheers for healthcare
workers some people got really good at
baking
many found a way to re-weave their
social tapestry
indeed across multiple large data sets
levels of loneliness
showed only a modest increase with 13.8
percent of adults in the us
compared with 11 in spring 2018.
people are incredible now here's the
thing
there was deep disastrous real pain
and hundreds and hundreds of thousands
of people have died of covet alone in
the united states
conspiracy theories aside lots and lots
and lots of people have suffered loss
in death plus car x plus lost jobs
plus terrifying financial conditions
all of it but hear what the author is
going to write
the astonishing resilience that most
people have exhibited in the face of the
sudden changes brought on by the
pandemic
hold its own lessons we learned that
people
can handle temporary changes to their
lifestyle such as working from home
giving up travel or even going into
isolation better than some
policy makers seem to have seemed to
assume
and here's why this is super super
important we've got
big time challenges on the horizon big
time challenges whether they be
financial whether they be ecological
whether they
be political whether they be
psychological whether they be
whatever here's what the authors write
human beings are not passive victims of
change but active stewards of our own
well-being
this knowledge should empower us to make
the disruptive changes our society
societies may require even as we support
the individuals and communities that
have been hit
the hardest what does that mean
it means that we as a society as a group
as individuals are hardwired to be
terrified of change
terrified of it so scared
and yet after what has been one of the
most
difficult and challenging crisis i don't
think it's over by a long shot
most difficult crisis many of us have
faced in our lifetimes collectively
our brains are solving for it our
relationships are solving for it we are
figuring out other ways we are getting
creative we are getting frustrated we
are
charting new paths we are slowly
recalibrating relationships we are
getting rid of stuff that we've been
carrying around with us for a long time
we're deciding we are gonna make changes
in our lives
and our bodies are saying cool we're
safe now
and so if you've got hard changes to
make
whether like today's calls whether it's
lorraine saying i
want to stop hurting people i want to
stop being so exhausted all the time
i want to stop being judge and jury or
whether it's like chris who
who wants to stop judging people who
have less than him
or wants to stop feeling guilty about
being successful
in his new job as new enterprise or it's
you you want to stop an addiction
you want to get control of your health
be good stewards of your mental health
learn how to have relationships and get
connected learn how to change your
thoughts
learn how to start acting differently
you can you can
this pandemic has been disastrous for
many of us
millions and millions worldwide but it's
also shown us a glimpse of light through
the cracks
we are strong and we are resilient
especially when we figure things out
together
so we'll link to that in the show notes
if you want to read it it's a really
remarkable read and again
just a little bit of light at the end of
the tunnel for some of us
all right so as we wrap up today's show
listen
i'm gonna dedicate this song to my good
friend kelly
i don't know why you're not a raging
alcoholic i just think it's funny
and um i might be after this show you
are correct
um so i am a closet
lover of swing music i love it love it
love it with all my heart
and the thing i love most about good
swing music a is it makes you shake your
body
just it just makes your body move and me
they take the most the darkest lyrics
and they wrap it around
really happy music and so i find myself
just singing and all of a sudden
i think ah that's a sad song
and so here we are with
one of my favorite songs of all time hey
listen
stop the recording when this like right
when i say these lyrics
stop the recording and pull the song up
it will make your day better and then
you'll start singing along and you'll
realize ah it's kind of a dark song
but this is a song for kelly and it's
called you and me
and the bottle makes three tonight and
it goes like this
hey jack i know what you're thinking
that now's this
as good as any to start drinking hey
scotty yeah
what's it gonna be a gin and a tonic
sounds mighty mighty good to me
that's got kelly's number man i gotta go
it's the same thing
every time but i don't think another
drink's gonna make me lose my mind
so i think about my next drink and it's
gotta be you
and me and the bottle makes three
tonight
[Music]
what a sad song you and me in the
bottlenecks three tonight
kelly there's help for you too right
here on the dr john dolone show